yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Thomas Tallis and he's not going
to play whoa interesting playing into
the main lines I wanted to say which is
true what what is he doing here that's
interesting playing this with the night
if desired looks very logical grabbing
this central space okay
interesting what is he going to you now
something you have something like that
and try to open up for the position for
the light side immediately does not work
I mean I can't take that that's pretty
certain but surname he's got very good
development still
yeah I think I should take and after
knight c6 can I enter this my
development wasn't good and this way at
least I'm covering sensitive squares
like d5 and and b5 so let's see to
activate the bishop on the long diagonal
there's going to be a nice piece let's
see ya know I'm not quite sure where you
should put the night maybe d2 to see
form that's a good square where pod
structure looks bad but pieces are are
active yeah this is active first and
foremost not interested in playing the
upon that would be a tempo on the night
but this is just a good way to play it
so let's check them I could play Bishop
h6 and harass him
and only don't lead to all that much
would be to doesn't work who takes
Bishop Jake's 52 back so how to do it
maybe that is annoying please sir it's a
bit annoying I should trade one look I
don't know if should be three is ever an
issue so let's take this and now I still
don't have the capture available I
inspect going is week ish but doesn't
really do much maybe I should do this to
have you fall ready in case of Bishop f3
and also Bishop e6 in some cases yeah
there should be six is something that
would and most definitely equalize your
pre will take it and then with opposite
colored bishops nothing much happens
this is the more interesting move yeah
but described threaten anything if I do
this he has to go away from the
half-open file
[Music]
yeah it's really nothing much him yeah
this is very simplistic but ok let's do
it keep it simple yeah possible keep
always allow into ki can play the ship
see one also let's go Bishop Simone it
takes e4 i'm going to take on d 2 with
the rook which is very drawn to say the
least extremely drawers yeah we'll
probably just trade rooks or take on a 5
which amounts to the same thing then i
have to trade on e to
this fan I'm getting this pawn which
doesn't really mean much maybe this time
morning for being a little bit more
active making light march to be too is
that could be interesting because the a
pawn not so easy to defend I expect you
one no ok now i can try to go to the
airport still look slightly problematic
I can defend all my points that we
should be three easily it is not quickly
tool to my upon so how is he defending
it has to probably move the pawn forward
now we cannot move it forward so this
I'm finding a vinegar spawn yep wicking
is imprisoned oh ok let's see then that
was a mistake now I'm promoting but
maybe didn't happen I many couldn't
defend it anyway not sure
not my job to find it out if he could
have defend this now we can all play
reality yeah not attending you should
win but tomorrow worked out here yeah
i'm not sure i think this is probably
equal this position let's see and i tend
to forget to switch under analysis you
yeah i think this should probably be
equal his pawn structure is excellent
but I've got the two bishops and I have
got fired yeah with a bed for porn
structure you have open files like to be
from so oh no it was too quick so this I
think you can argue about some things
but so don't think we ever had something
that was really unbalanced sole traders
5cm that's a debatable decision for sure
I was also the engine move I also
understand yeah push to look here it
would be nice if i could get to the
default i cannot move my my bishop and
the engine wants to reroute to d6 that's
a really good idea yeah the picture is
good on d6 covers all the crucial dark
squares and now it switches to e5 and
well that wasn't bad I think what I did
was certainly a sensible option but
shouldn't have led to any advantage he
took within 90 minutes is equal it's
just equal I thought he takes that fire
force a little bit more sense would it
really it is a draw really should be a
draw well see form probably after mean
my king is a bit more actor
yeah i went with with this to simply get
rid of the the weakness now I have
something when my pants are completely I
easily defended in our enter so yes and
here's the problem Bishop c6 was better
and put it here and play for him that
that there's going to be the end of all
ideas problem yeah but this is already
getting a little bit inconvenient and
making sure that the airport doesn't
move so now I'm winning this and I know
am I also winning the game yeah Bishop
f5 log given by the engine yeah to go to
d3 okay I could have played skin before
you already I wanted to do this first
but yeah it hits already told them so
the engine wants to defend like this so
I way for QB to okay so then let's just
say I'm putting and whatever i'm putting
this up when I cannot sue crying in
there that's the thing he can always
defend those to the king is blocking the
service this was the draw
okay guys thanks for watching